[Music]
[Applause]
bring back one of our favorites Troy
Aman joining us on behalf of his
successful light beer8 Elite light
logger 100% organic grains no cheap
fillers and only 90 calories 2.6 gram of
carbs eight truly light beer made right
never settle for anything less we bring
in TR Roy Aman joining us on the program
how's uh how's the beer company going
there Troy it's doing well yeah we're uh
we're starting our third year and uh a
lot of good things yeah we're expecting
a big year and you're right uh light
beer made right 100% organic grains 2.6
carbs 90 calories and uh the best part
is no added syrups or sugars and uh it's
really resonated so uh it's doing really
well it's just in Texas but we're
launching can't announce exactly where
we're going but here in a few months uh
we're going just a little north of here
so okay you know we're expanding a
little bit so that's good maybe a place
where you started your college football
career uh yes possibly uh possibly could
be sure but when you drank at halftime
when you were with the Cowboys what did
you normally drink uh I didn't drink
eight uh but yeah it was a competitor of
ours now did uh anybody I worked at a I
worked at a brewery in uh in Tulsa
before when I transferred from Oklahoma
to to UCLA uh I worked at a
distributorship uh up that way and uh
that was my my my first introduction uh
into the beer industry wait did you just
show up and get a paycheck or did you
was this name image and likeness before
nio yeah unfortunately you know people
ask me how much I got when I to go to
Oklahoma or UCLA or you know I I was I
wasn't uh really highly sought after so
I I didn't get any of those those types
of perks I I put in the work uh so and
that's who the beer's made for Dan so
it's all good uh if you were going to
give Brock pie advice this week what
would you tell
him you know the advice that I got
before my first Super Bowl was really
just to be as prepared mentally as you
possibly could be so that so that you
could just go play and you know the
advice that a lot of people give is hey
treat it like any other game it it's
it's not like any other game and anyone
who suggests that it is hasn't played in
the Super Bowl uh you you don't arrive a
week early for any other game and
obviously the
attention uh but for him trying to keep
the week as normal as possible and
that's hard to do but my guess is that's
his approach every week and and he'll be
able to get it done but I you know Dan
the thing that I'm always most
interested in
seeing Patrick Mahomes has been in these
games so you know he won't won't be as
affected as much but someone like Brock
pie who hasn't uh how do they handle the
ball early in the game you know what
what do you see from them what's their
demeanor uh is the moment excuse me is
the moment too big for them but I'm
looking forward to seeing how he handles
it but what kind of distractions did you
have with your first Super Bowl off the
field you know I was really fortunate in
that uh our first game our first Super
Bowl was at the Rose Bowl we practiced
at UCLA where I had just finished my
college career four years earlier we had
the equipment guys who helped our staff
uh from my college days that were around
so a lot of the support people there at
our practices and in the locker room
were people that I was familiar with so
everything for me was very comfortable
uh which which definitely helped and
then we dressed in the locker room where
I played my college games as well and
then of course at the rosebowl so uh
there really was not there was not any
distractions to speak of for me and I
thought that Jimmy Johnson he was always
really good uh during the week on
Wednesday he'd come in and he'd give a
speech to the team and it wasn't always
the same speech it really was dialed
into whatever team it was that we were
playing that week but the week of that
first Super Bowl in '92 the 92 season I
thought Jimmy was as good as he had ever
been in his messaging to the team CU we
were the youngest team in football uh
and he prepared us uh really well well I
thought how often would you show up at
practice and somebody would say oh did
you hear what happened with one of your
teammates uh well it didn't happen a lot
when Jimmy was our head coach but when
Jim but when Jimmy decided to go to
South Florida uh yeah there were there
were there were a few of those mornings
where you came in and said no you got to
be kidding so it was a little looser
under Barry Switzer than Jimmy Johnson a
little yeah that's a good way of putting
it yeah but you never got in
trouble uh I miss curfew under Chan gayy
and training camp I guess that's about
as much trouble as
wow I had an interest who I in in in a
in a woman and I I went on to marry her
and I just felt it was one of those
moments where you got to make a decision
Dan and I decided that I was going to
Mis curf you and ride this thing out and
uh the the security guard uh un
unfortunately I thought he was a friend
but he
turned he ratted you out he ratted me
out yeah yeah you should have tipped him
you should have you know greased the
Palm there a little bit there uh we're
talking to Troy Aman joining us on
behalf of his successful light beer it's
eight Elite logger Chief's defense
doesn't get enough credit I guess
because if you have momes and Kelce and
Taylor Swift and everything that goes
along with that but uh what would
concern you if you were playing that
defense this weekend
well I just think that what Steve
spagnolo does is is is so good the
different looks that he gives the
blitzes that he that he has he's been
doing it a long time I I totally agree
with you I think that you know it
happens it it happened with our teams
that when you when you have a a really
good offense the defense tends to get
overlooked it happened with San
Francisco and the runs that they had uh
yeah this Kansas City defense is is
really good so it's not uh it's not one
of those situations where it's all on
Patrick Mahomes and it hasn't been I
mean this defense has done a good job
throughout the year so uh I just I think
the challenge is is is being able to
pick up the different looks that they
give uh and that's not an easy task uh
Brock p is going to face that defense uh
where do you see where you would take
advantage of and and can Brock P do the
same thing well I I I love everything
about San Francisco I I think in a time
when you're not able to practice the the
way that you once were able to and yet
this is a team that is extremely
physical on both sides of the ball and
how they accomplish that it hasn't
mattered who their defensive coordinator
is or the coaches that they've lost on
the offensive side of the ball uh they
play a style that that that I love to
see and then then the scheme in which
they run it reminds me a lot of the
teams that I was a part of I think
Kyle's I think he's the best head coach
in football I mean I I I think he's the
best offensive guy in football right now
and the way they tie it all together has
allowed Brock you still have to make
those throws so I'm not in the camp of
saying that that Brock is a game manager
at all uh but with the running game and
then the play action game and the way
that they go through the progressions uh
it takes away a a a lot of I guess the
challenging aspects of playing against a
defense like this uh because you're
going through your reads and you get the
ball to the guy who's open uh which
sounds simple but you just don't have to
read it out quite like you do in some
other offenses can you say this on the
record that Kansas City is now America's
team uh I don't know that I can say that
uh with my with my allegiance to to the
Cowboys but you know yeah they've
they've they've certainly captured the
country and with Taylor Swift and the
the you know Army of fans that she's
brought to the sport has been fantastic
and and and they're one of those teams
now like we saw from New England for
several years and we were a part of that
the Steelers of 49ers that you know
they're to be reckoned with each and
every year what they what they've
accomplished even up to this point uh is
is really impressive so uh yeah but
nobody embraced the
Patriots all that success they weren't
America's team whereas the Niners had
their run the Packers had their run the
Steelers had their run the Cowboys had
their run and fan bases were built off
of that I don't know if America ever bra
embraced the Patriots why do you say
that because I think in New England they
did uh are are you if you were a
Patriots fan you embraced them just like
I guess if you're a Chiefs fan you
embrace the Chiefs I you know and they
they then you bring some people in I
mean I I would imagine that they
cultivated the Patriots that is that
they cultivated some fans by the fact
that they were winning uh you know in my
childhood I always rooted for the
winners so you know people say who was
your team and I said well whoever was
winning at the time was my team you know
I had I had a lot of teams over the
years you're like kids nowadays they do
that they just like players you know
maybe not a team what would Elevate uh
Patrick Mahomes to Tom Brady's level in
your
mind oh
I you know Dan for me it's it's
championships I mean it it sounds
self-serving when I say that because I
was able to win three but at the end of
the day the reason that he's getting
paid $50 million a year is to win
championships it's why all quarterbacks
are it's why they're drafted where they
were drafted uh and and Tom understood
that better than anyone uh you know he
sacrificed a lot in order to win
championships so to I I don't like the
the conversation to say well Patrick
Mahomes is the greatest quarterback of
all time I mean I I just don't know how
you can say that at this stage of his
career he's certainly on Pace uh but he
hasn't even surpass you
Troy well yeah I mean well that's a good
point I mean you do you do have three
and he's got two so there's a reason why
I like coming on your show D so you know
but no I I think in order to say that it
with Tom I think you've got to win seven
or you've got to win eight I I I do
think that's the measuring stick and and
it's hard to imagine that anyone uh
there was a time when I didn't think
anybody could beat Joe Montana or Terry
Bradshaw and win five and then he's gone
on in you know 17 so I guess that's the
bar also you I don't know if you were
criticized but it's you had all these
weapons and I don't know if people said
well you know just don't screw up or
anybody can win like Terry Bradshaw he
was criticized by you know people said
well you should win you're you know the
quarterback of the Steelers but Brock
pie is getting this criticism how much
criticism did you get winning Super
Bowls where they were like well just
hand it to EMT and occasionally throw it
to Mike
yeah I I the people that say that make
it sound like you know playing the
position is easy and uh you know and
it's and it's anything but I I
never I never concern myself with any of
that but I will say this that for those
with that talk about Brock perie as hey
he's a he's a product of the system uh
he's a game manager I have yet maybe you
have I haven't I've yet to hear a
quarterback say that because I think the
quarterbacks understand that when you
say game manager then then you fail to
appreciate the third and 12 throw that
he converted between two Defenders for a
first down that allowed Christian
mcaffrey then to score from the five
yard line I I you know those are the
things that that tend to get lost so uh
Joe Montana had great players around him
I had great players around me Bradshaw
has great players around him you know
all all you you can't win in this game
unless you have good players around you
and then along with what you said a
moment ago about having a good defense
so all of that goes hand inand but you
know anyone who criticizes me or thinks
hey all he had to do was this or that
you know I I've never lost any sleep
over I don't care I mean it just has not
it's not been relevant to me yeah and we
get caught up in that game manager I'm
thinking maybe if we change it to game
Commander or game CEO it I think the
word manager is the problem like you
know the word meatloaf is not doesn't
sound good but if we change it to meat
Mountain then it would sound tasty so I
love meatloaf so you know with I'm okay
I'm okay with me are you okay with game
game manager well it's better than what
parcel's used to say he used to just
call him a bus driver so you know I
mean poor Phil Sims yeah poor Phil Sim
yeah uh hey good luck uh always great to
talk to you thanks for spending time
with us thank you Dan have a great week
that's uh T Roy Aman joining us on
behalf of his Beer Company eight Elite
light logger headed to Oklahoma perhaps